[Music]
the internet is full of all sorts of
life hacks and tips that many of them
don't involve everyday object so what
are some things hiding in your home that
you can use to make your life easier if
you are a first-time viewer click the
red subscribe button and prepare to be
amazed
today we are discussing 20 life tips
that will completely change the way you
look at ordinary things remove deodorant
from clothing no one is immune to
getting pesky deodorant marks on their
dark clothing so luckily there is a
simple solution just scrunch up a used
dryer sheet and rub off the deodorant
mark with it it's important that the
dryer sheet is fused or you can make the
mark work soothe a sore throat it may be
strange to think that's something that
makes your hot dog so tasty can actually
help sooth your sore throat but it's
true all you have to do is combine juice
of half a lemon one tablespoon of salt
one tablespoon of honey and half a cup
of boiling water let the mixture cool
down and then gargle with it a few times
warning it won't taste good but it will
help breath freshener considering coffee
is something that can cause smelly
breath it's hard to believe a coffee
bean can freshen breath but if you are
out of men's just pop it dry coffee bean
in your mouth and you will have fresh
breath in no time take saucer if you are
a novice Baker there is an easy frosting
hack you have to try turn your blow
dryer on low heat and blow-dry your
frosted good this will give them a
professional fluffy finish get rid of
ink stains if you ever had a pen break
and leak on your coatings and we know
how much of a nightmare ink stains are
to remove first filthy area with acetone
next select the area with spirit of
Hawthorne also known as baker's ammonia
the stain should be out with minimal
effort by by headaches if you suffer
from horrible headaches there is a trick
you may want to try it sounds crazy but
it's worth the shot cut a lemon into
slices and rub one of the slices on your
forehead the aroma of citrus has a
calming effect that can help eliminate
the headache remove glue from glass
buying new glassware for your home can
be awesome for the price tag sometimes
leave unwanted goo stain these can
easily be removed with cooking oil soak
the stain with the oil for 10 minutes
then simply lip it off with a paper
towel
I sit this can be the worst but the
solution to fighting them can be founded
right in your freezer wrap an ice cube
with a washcloth and apply it to the hit
for a minute or two the ice will cause
the spot to be red and it helps reduce
swelling just make sure not to leave the
ice on your skin for too long
Flattr substitute for those of you who
love cookies but our students adjust to
the butter used in the recipe there is
an easy slop you can easily use coconut
oil instead of butter for any of your
bikini coconut oil is a necessity for
people who are lactose intolerant cat
training moving into a new home yet
could be a bit stressful for cat you can
help your cat get adjusted by wiping
butter on their paws not only is it a
little treat but it will help your cat
get used to surrounding while it's
looking a butter off remove crayon from
walls anyone with children knows blank
walls can be a blank canvas for their
little artist luckily there is something
that can remove crayon from walls
superfast just use a pencil eraser to
erase the crayon mark make sure to do a
spot test first to see if the eraser
damages your wall paint keeper dry
cleaning if you're tired of only getting
one wear out of your dryclean only
clothing there is a quick hack that can
extend your time between dry clean all
you have to do is get a spray bottle and
add water and vodka to make a diluted
vodka solution next spray the solution
on your smelling dry clean only clothes
this will help get the sell out but it
won't help with sane check an egg eggs
can be a bit tricky when it comes to
figuring out if they are still fresh if
you aren't sure about your eggs do the
floating test drop the egg in cold water
if it's fresh it will sink if it floats
it's time to toss it treat bruises
bruises are not only painful but they
can be unsightly if you want a way to
treat your bruises just look at the item
next to your toothbrush dance on a
cotton ball with mouthwash and apply it
to a bruise to help diminish the
appearance of the bruise calm yourself
down if you are someone who suffers from
a bit of anxiety the next tip may be for
you take your thumb and press it down on
the skin between your nose and your lips
for three seconds dry Footwear if you
are someone who lives in an area who has
a ton of rain then let's use maybe
something you're used to if you want to
dry it in quickly try this trick heat up
some salt in a frying pan
pour into a dry soft next place a sock
into a Lex you your shoes will dry in no
time
dried out lemon it may seem like a dried
out lemon as useless but don't throw it
away just yet you can make a dried-out
lemon good as new by soaking it in water
for a few hours
pace medicine easier taking liquid
medicine is never easy but sometimes
it's necessary if you have a hard time
taking less than tasty medicine try this
hat stuck on an ice cube until your
tongue is numb
next fit off the ice and take the
medicine immediately your tongue can't
taste anything when it's numb so you own
tad on the bitter medicine swing your
windshield most of the time we welcome
spring by the splatter of bugs all over
our wind chills for an easy way to get
rid of those pesky bug stains try this
spray your windshield with water and use
a dryer sheets to wipe your wing so
clean protect your smart phone smart
phones have become almost an extension
of ourselves so it's important to keep
the protective if you notice the few
scratches on your phone I'll protect it
with some toothpaste just put some
toothpaste on a cloth and rub the screen
of your smartphone make sure the cracks
are filled and rub the remaining
toothpaste off your phone until it's dry
what do you think of these life chips
using ordinary things react in the
comment section below and don't forget
to like this video and subscribe to the
things
[Music]